(introductory hip-hop music)
- Well welcome back to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
It's my pleasure to continue
to host these conversations.
I've definitely been
appreciative of the engagement
of all of you as listeners,
and today I'm very excited to be able
to host a conversation
on justice, activism,
and the church with
Rev. Dr. Otis Moss, III.
Dr. Moss, thanks so much
for being here on the Addy Hour podcast.
- It is my pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
- Of course.
And we have had the opportunity
to interact previously.
Dr. Moss and I were part
of a provocative panel back
in September of '22 entitled,
Is Christianity Bad
For Your Mental Health?
So you can just imagine
some of the conversations
that came up there,
but really excited to be able
to interact again in this way.
And just by way of introduction,
for those who may not be
familiar with Dr. Moss,
want to just let you know
that he is the senior pastor
of Trinity United Church of
Christ in Chicago, Illinois.
He is a preacher, an
activist, and an author.
And also, over the last two decades,
he's someone who has practiced
and preached a Black theology
that unapologetically calls
attentions to the problems
of mass incarceration,
environmental justice,
and economic inequality.
He is a native of Cleveland, Ohio,
an honors graduate of Morehouse College.
He also has a master's of divinity
from the Yale Divinity School,
so home turf in a sense for me,
and a doctorate of ministry
from Chicago Theological Seminary.
He is currently a professor in
the McAfee School of Theology
at Mercer University.
And he is someone who is
a third-generation warrior
for civil and human rights.
He's committed to preaching
a prophetic message of love
and justice, which he believes
are inseparable companions
that form the foundation of
the gospel of Jesus Christ.
I should also mention,
this is a legacy for him,
both personally and in
terms of his family.
He's been heavily influenced
and has a foundation
from his father, Dr. Otis Moss Jr.,
and also from Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.
whom his father worked with at
one point as well, so again,
just to give you all just
a little bit of insight,
I know we'll hear more but
just appreciate the work
that you continue to do and
your willingness to be here
for this podcast conversation.
- Thank you, I'm honored.
- Excellent.
And as my listeners know,
one of the benefits of these
conversations is we have a lot
of guests who are just
generous with their openness
and being willing to peel
back the layers as it were.
So I wanted to just do a check-in
and see how you're doing
at this point in time.
With everything that we've
experienced as a society
and especially, soberingly,
with just all of the
challenges around gun violence,
both the mass shootings
that seem to be happening
on a weekly basis, and all
of the other gun violence
that does not get that same
national attention, so just,
if you're willing to share how
you're doing at this point.
- I appreciate that.
Right now, I am, I use the
word okay, when you say,
you know, scale of one to 10,
that usually means like five.
(both laugh)
So I'm in the middle.
I received a call that one
of our deacons actually
found his younger brother
who had committed suicide
by hanging unfortunately.
- Oh, wow.
- And he found the body
and just a, just devastating.
- Oh my goodness.
- And right before
getting on this podcast,
one of our members just
sent us a text that she went
to the hospital to see her father, she,
her father was at assisted living place,
but they never called her to share
that he was being
transferred to the hospital.
She gets to the hospital,
no one had called her,
no one said anything,
and her father's gone.
- Wow.
- And you know, just, you
know, the weight of, you know,
those two people that walking with them
as they are preparing
for home goings, both in,
one, how should I say it, one
who had lived a beautiful,
long life, and then one where, you know,
you have a family that's
with, as it is with suicide,
you raise questions and
trying to walk with the family
and let them know that
this is not punishment,
your loved one is loved by God
and God's arm, all of that,
without all of the noise
and trash that seep
into our subconscious
because we had such horrific pastoral care
and just bad theology and just bad public,
civic conversation about people
who just really are looking
for individuals to support them
and to walk with them and love them.
- Exactly, well--
- So I'm at a five.
I'm at a five, I'm at a five,
just doing what, you know,
what you do in the Black
churches, you know,
trying to, you know, to walk with people
in their most vulnerable moments.
- Yeah.
Well definitely appreciate your level
of honesty just in talking
about where you are at this point in time,
and I know that a lot
of listeners, you know,
especially those who have experience
or are in the Black church can
relate to that piece as well,
but some listeners might
also even feel surprised
to hear you say that you're at a five
with that level of heaviness
that you often have to walk through.
But you know, you touched
on so many important pieces
in terms of meeting
people where they're at
but then just all of the
noise that can come as well.
Just to maybe even peel
back a little bit more
even before we jump into
some of the other topics,
how do you as a pastor and
a faith leader navigate that
for those that you are
ministrating to with all the noise,
trying to help them navigate
but then also trying to
make sure that it's framed
in the right way, both for
them, for their families,
for the church, for society?
I know that's a very large
question, but just curious,
anything you wanna elaborate.
- Well I think
on a personal level,
it is important that you
are grounded in community,
you know, your own community.
I'm not talking about, quote unquote,
just the church community
because for those
who are pastors who're
probably listening to,
the most difficult thing is
pastors need to be pastored,
pastors need to have a community
in which they are nurtured
and cared, so that they
can be good caregivers,
especially during moments of
vulnerability and challenge.
And so being in a community,
there's your family and
then there are people
that're around you that support you,
so that's one of the things,
and then having the
appropriate spiritual practices
for yourself, you know, the
time of silence, you know,
mindfulness, prayer,
music for me has always been very helpful.
And as a spiritual practice,
listening to and spending
time just listening to music
that puts you in a particular
place, and reading.
Reading scripture,
I'm going through a book
right now called "The Teaching
"of Christian Mystics," basically,
and so what I do is I read out loud,
because reading out loud
changes things, number one.
Number two, most of what we read
that is ancient was never
meant to be read in your head.
This is oral transmission,
so why do we become so modern
and say, "Oh, I'll read this in my head,"
but when you read out loud,
all of a sudden the phrasing,
the voice, the pause catches you
in a different way than
when you read something
in your head.
I mean, I'm encouraging,
I teach and I encourage
my students, I say,
"Before you even go to a scripture
"and you're gonna start
trying to work on a sermon,
"I want you to read it out
loud and then read it out loud
"in five different translations, you know,
"and watch what happens."
Just by reading, you're not
trying to force anything,
or, just read it and it becomes
a great meditative process
and discipline to read out loud,
and to read because,
for example, I'm sorry
I'm talking so long,
I know it's about my job,
- No, it's good. (laughs)
- but, like if you say
the Lord is my shepherd,
or do you say, the Lord is my shepherd?
Or do you say, the Lord is my shepherd?
Now, all the exact same words,
but based on the usage of your voice,
a different meaning comes forth,
and different emotion is presented.
That's why reading out loud,
reading poetry out loud,
reading scripture out loud,
and that's why we sing songs out loud.
(both laugh)
- Yep.
- Like songs in my head,
no, you start, you know,
start singing it.
You know, I mean, it's one
thing to say it in your head
but out, you know, singing
it out, thinking, you know,
becomes a powerful art form.
- Mm, well, that's so
powerful and so good.
I know people are listening to that
and even just reflecting.
I mean, even just that simple phrase
that you had in three different ways,
just the power that comes from that.
And I mean, you also
talked about community
and then maybe we're
getting off script here too,
but how do you see those
two pieces going together?
Especially as a pastor, I
mean, with things that happen,
not just in our congregations
- You know, we're--
- but in the world and as we
navigate them as communities?
- I think community's necessary
for human flourishing.
We're designed as community creatures.
You know, we were created in
community to be in community.
Genesis talks about humanity being alone.
It's not good to be alone.
There are times you need to be alone.
(laughs) Lemme add that.
But we learn in community,
we are nurtured in community,
we develop in community, and
when we experience trauma,
we come out of trauma
or learn how to navigate trauma
through healthy community.
And without a healthy community, it's not,
you are not able to
flourish as a human being,
and you're not able to
reach your full potential.
You need to be in a healthy community,
and when families are unhealthy,
families are community,
it takes a toll on your soul,
and you have to place yourself in a space
where you can be in and
around healthy people,
and that's one of the
aspects of the Black church.
And I say the Black church
specifically, that they're,
in a church there are
multiple communities,
and when you find the space
of the appropriate community,
an intergenerational community
of elders and younger people,
people who are middle-aged,
some who are married and some who are not
and you have this potpourri
of people in your garden,
are providing aspects for human
development, and you know,
it's kinda like, just
like a regular garden.
You know, some people are like basil,
some people are like mint.
(both laugh)
So you know, you know, some
people are like rose bushes
but got a whole lotta thorns,
you know, so you know,
and you have to know that
they're not all the same
and together, they give all
of the necessary nutrients
for a person to truly flourish.
- That's so wonderful
to hear and you know,
my listeners have heard
me talk about community
in lots of different settings,
often bringing up just the
biology of what that does
in our brains and the social binds,
so it's so nice to hear
from a holistic perspective,
just to hear you actually emphasize
and talk about community
within the church,
how important that is for our soul,
and all these different pieces together
and how that really helps us navigate,
and even as we've talked
about things like traumas
as you hinted at, and how people
walk through that together
as a community,
and just the ways that God has designed us
to be in community,
the ways we can see that show
up in our biological changes,
the way we can see that in
psychological processes,
the way we can see that on
the global scale, and again,
it just seems, in so many ways,
that the heart of what you
are doing in your roles,
even as I think about
what you've talked about
in terms of mental health but also some
of the social justice work,
thinking about criminal injustices,
just the activism and the
family history that you have,
how does that aspect of community for you,
what does that actually
look like across all
of these different spectrums?
Because again, people, you know,
might be hearing about and saying,
well you're touching on so
many different components,
and how do you tie those all together?
- Hm, that's an interesting question.
How do we tie them all together?
Well for me, I was raised in a space
that believed that the
Black community is varied
and diverse, and it is also
your responsibility not only
to be a part of,
but to ensure that this
community is thriving.
So be a part and thriving,
so there's, you know,
there's kinda the church,
you know, community,
there's what I would call,
like for those who've gone
to HBCUs, you know,
there's another community
that develops off of that.
If you went to a PWI,
you've created your own little
community on that level.
Then there're the community
that you have at your work.
Then there's the family community,
then there's the community of friends,
friends that you've developed
as a child, grew up with,
friends that you have connected with
during your adulting process which is,
some is called college,
or if you are, you know,
you're in apprentice program,
or whatever it may be,
or the military, and then
there are friends that develop
as a result of common trauma
and tragedy that you end up
developing relationships with,
and then there are the people that you,
a person that you choose
to be your life partner,
that I would hope would be
your best friend, you know,
that you should go down that road.
All of those communities make
the fullness of who we are.
And all of those communities
have their North Star
and also have moments where
the stars are obscured
and they get off course.
All of those communities.
That's just a part, if you
dare to claim to be human
and you seek to live your call,
you will deal with those issues.
But all these aspects
of community though make up who you are
and make up who we see
as our wider community.
And I'm, you know, speaking, you know,
from the perspective of someone
who is out of the African
American community,
and there're some very unique
aspects to our community,
I mean, just like barber
shop community, you know?
I mean that, I like
going to the barber shop
and that community of
people, usually brothers,
especially when they, you know,
start arguing about sports and start lying
about other stuff,
there's something that's
very endearing about being
in that space and there's
something stress-relieving
about being in that space
as someone, you know,
they're cutting your hair,
you know, you get the hookup,
you know, with the cut and
whatnot and you get your,
you know, to argue or hear a whole bunch
of ridiculous theories about the world,
there's no other space
where people get a chance
to communicate, lie, promote.
(both laugh)
- It's all there.
- It's everything, it's
everything in those spaces.
You know, it's similar to when, you know,
people gather together
and they play Spades
or something of that nature,
you have that level of energy sometimes,
but you know, comes about.
- Yeah.
And some surprises that aren't surprises
in terms of the things that
come out of people's mouths,
but it's healthy too.
- Oh my gosh.
(Nii laughs)
Yeah, yeah, it is.
It's fascinating, it's just,
it's the best comedy in the
world is in the barber shop,
because you have some
of the best storytellers
and they're telling stories
that are absolutely not true
and everybody knows it, but we
still want to hear the story,
no matter what, because they're
such a good storyteller.
- Yep, yep.
I mean even, not to make it
too academic all of a sudden,
but I know there's a lot
of initiatives just even using that space
and all the benefits of it to
actually help people open up
about mental health challenges,
because that's a lot of,
that's the first point of
contact for a lot of people,
so that, be able to be
equipped in that way
to notice something,
to touch on it in the space
where there's already that sense
of community has been really important
in a lot of communities just
for really pushing that
conversation forward.
- Yeah, Chicago, we have
a couple members here
who were part of public health initiatives
where they were using the barber shop
for the public health
initiative for, you know,
people getting checked,
getting tested, all of that,
but also for mental health check-in,
and now there is an initiative
around barber shop books,
placing in barber shops,
books for young people.
They can take them, you know,
there's no cost to them.
You know, they say, "Hey,
you can take and," you know,
it's kinda like read and return,
and so there's been this
new movement around literacy
in connection to barber shops.
Literacy and mental health I think
also go directly together.
You give people spaces
where they're able to read
and to imagine and to rethink,
and to see themselves in spaces
that they never would
normally think of themselves,
and that's one of the powers
I think of Afrofuturism,
the idea of seeing Black people
in a variety of ways, not,
I read an article years ago,
it was called "The Documentary
Impulse in Black Film,"
and you know, I was kinda
like, what is this article?
What is this about?
And I started reading, I
was like, oh, I get it.
The writer was saying
that for everybody else,
when we write something
or something is presented,
we get to say it's fiction.
But for Black people,
no matter even (chuckles) if
it's just run of the mill,
it's like, oh yeah,
this is really like a documentary
because this is the way Black people are.
We don't even get to play.
We don't even get to fantasize,
because we're always told,
no, it has to be real.
And that's the beauty of
Afrofuturism is that it allows us
to expand our imagination
and one of the most dangerous things
is to have a colonized imagination
that limits your ability to be able
to witness what you can be or
what your community can be.
- Yeah.
Well that's so, so important.
I'm glad your bringing that up,
and just reminds me of a lot of the work
that you're already doing,
just in terms of Afrofuturism
but then also the power
of community to change narratives, I mean,
as you were talking about with literacy
as with mental health.
And I know you as a church have done a lot
of work around that,
even from individuals who
were formerly incarcerated,
and how you've been changing
the narrative there as well.
So I'd be curious if you'd
just be willing to talk
about that a little bit
for our listeners to know,
to hear about some of
those innovative things
that you're doing to really
shift perspective, expectation,
and opportunity.
- Well, one of the things that we, well,
let me just begin this way,
that there are three pillars
to any type of community
development work we do here
at Trinity. We've done a lot
of community development work,
and I'll explain a little bit more
about community development work.
But the three pillars
are economic development,
that in other words, our
community must benefit.
And the second pillar is
that it must be sustainable,
it must be green.
And so there must be some sustainability,
must be a green initiative.
And then the third pillar is,
it must disrupt the mass
incarceration system.
So it has to have those reasons,
we've gotta benefit from
it, it's gotta be green,
and it's got to disrupt,
so I like to say that
it's gotta be blessed
by Black folk and Black
folk gotta be blessed by it.
It's gotta be green in terms of things
that we're gonna flow into
our pockets and to our bank,
and it's also got to bind
the wounds of the blood
that's been shed as a result
of mass incarceration,
so I'd like to say it's red,
black, and green, you know,
to borrow from Marcus Garvey.
(both chuckle)
But what we did with one
of first initiatives,
we renovated our church and
we renovated the church green.
Green statement,
we wanted to make a
LEED-certified building.
In doing that, we said, one,
the contractors must be Black.
Two, those working on this
building must be people
who come from the mass
incarceration system.
Three, it has to be green.
And this was kind of a challenge
because most people who were bidding
and things of that nature,
"We've never done this before,"
was like, "Well you can work with us,
"this is the way it works."
We are the primary contract,
you're a subcontractor,
so this is the way we're gonna do this.
And so we created and built, you know,
renovated our church in that manner.
Then at one of our next projects,
there's a library
literally down the street,
walking distance from our church,
has the largest collection of
African American literature
in the Midwest.
It's called the Carter G. Woodson Library.
The Vivian Harsh collection,
I mean they have letters of DuBois sent
to people in Chicago,
I mean it's primary resources,
if you're doing your PhD,
University of Chicago,
University of Illinois, DePaul,
you have to use this library,
but it's in the hood.
It's in our hood.
We have a great hood, by the way.
And so the building had
scaffolding around it,
not because the city was doing work,
but the original contractor did a poor job
and they were worried that
the bricks were gonna fall
on the heads of people
walking into the library.
- (blows out) Wow.
- And the scaffolding had
been out there for 20 years,
so people got used to it.
- Wow.
Community development corporation
just raised the question,
was like, "Why is there
scaffolding outside
"of the building?"
No one had raised the
question, it's like, well,
that's when we found the story,
and we organized with the community,
and when I say organized
with the community,
other community partners, other
organizations, block clubs,
you name it, and we found out
that the library's heavily
used, people love it,
but it is falling apart.
So we were going to the city and saying,
"Hey, we want you to
renovate the library."
And we already did our research.
There were five other libraries
that were either built new
from the ground up or renovated,
million-dollar renovations,
like five, 10, 15, and
$20 million renovations,
and they came back to us, they said,
"Oh, we don't have the money."
I said, "Well, you had the money
"in every white neighborhood."
(both laugh)
"But you didn't have the money
in the Black neighborhood."
So after this initial meeting,
at the very end
of the meeting I just
simply asked one question.
I said, "When's your next library meeting,
"the library commission meeting?"
And like, oh, they meet
once a month on like,
it was Wednesday I think.
And I said, "Thank you very much."
And unbeknownst to them, what
I did was I, the next Sunday,
I got up in the pulpit and I
shared with the congregation,
you know, what had happened, and I said,
"There's a library
commission meeting coming up
"on said date.
"We'd love it if you would show
up to express the importance
"of the library in the community."
Now, one must understand that
library commission meetings,
nobody goes to, unless you're
into the Dewey Decimal System.
No one goes to a library
commission meeting.
So on this library commission
meeting was so perfunctory,
they're boring, you know,
they go on for all of about
50 minutes and they, you know,
they go away, they said hey, you know,
we're gonna hire another
librarian or something.
And this library commission meeting,
all of these Black people show up.
I mean, and everybody
has the same question.
I wasn't at the meeting.
(Nii laughs)
They're asking this, "So you
built five other libraries,
"but you don't have the money
for the Carter G. Woodson?"
Please let that name sit.
Named after one of the greatest
historian intellectuals.
The reason that we have
Black History Month,
a Black History Week that was started
by Carter G. Woodson, you know,
"The Mis-Education of the
Negro," Carter G. Woodson,
and so the meeting ended at like,
let's say 7:59 I think it
was, I got a call at 8:01.
- Wow.
- And they were saying,
"Can we meet, you know,
"as soon as possible?"
I was like, "Sure, I'd be more
than happy to meet with you."
And so our team met with
the library commission
and they walk in, they
were smiling and they said,
"We want you to know,
we found $10 million.
"We got a $10 million grant,"
- That was quick,
that was quick. (laughs)
- It was that quick,
was that really quick,
"to rebuild the library,
"to renovate the library."
I was like, "Oh, that's really wonderful."
"So I want you to know that all
"of your concerns have
been taken care of."
We said, "No."
I said, "First of all, will
Black people benefit from it?
"Who will be the contractors?
"Second thing is, will
it be a green design?
"Third, will you use brothers and sisters
"from the mass incarceration
system to do the work?"
And they looked dumbfounded and said,
"Well, there's no policy to do that.
"We've never done
anything like that before.
"That would cost a lot.
"That would," you know,
they were just using cost
as an excuse.
And so we just said
back to them, and said,
"Our church did it."
Said, "If a church that doesn't
have the budget of a city,
"cities have billions of
dollars, is able to do this,
"why can't the city?"
Long story short, they ended
up using the same principles
that we used, and I would invite anyone
who comes to Chicago to see
this crown jewel library now.
The Carter G. Woodson
Library is astonishing.
It is one of the only libraries
in the city of Chicago
that specializes in
Alzheimer's and dementia,
so if you're a caregiver,
you can go to this library.
They have a studio in this library.
They have an amazing children's
section in this library.
There is an auditorium in this library.
You can have shows, and it's like,
it is truly a crown
jewel, and on top of that,
you have the largest collection
of African American
literature in the Midwest,
and it's smack dab in the
heart of the South Side
in the Black community,
and that's part of the
kind of development,
when I say community
development, is putting,
making sure that there is an institution
that everyone can utilize,
and a library is one of those spaces
that nobody argues about.
You know, you don't have, well,
well, down in Florida they're arguing
about what's in the
libraries, another story,
but usually libraries are
the one community space
that just about everybody can agree on
that we wanna make sure
that it's functioning well.
- Mm-hm.
Wow, that's, I mean, just
transformative in so many ways.
And just to know that
you all held your ground,
I mean there was a lot
of wisdom (chuckles)
in that negotiation
process I would call it,
but just showing the importance
of community as well.
I mean you touched on sustainability,
how has that played
out both in the library
and then what you all are doing just
in the community in general?
- Oh it's been awesome,
so the next phase for the
Community Development Corporation,
they started purchasing
homes in the neighborhood
that were on the, what you would call the,
part of the Cook County Land Bank.
They, tax delinquent homes.
You may get a home for 10,000
and they're falling apart,
you know, 10,000, $15,000.
And we had a developer who
was part of the church,
and he wanted to develop the homes
so that they would look like
they did in the suburbs,
high end, high end, high end development.
But we would not sell them
at anywhere at the cost
that they would valued at.
And there was a reason.
So let's say with the renovation,
they take, we get a home,
five, 10, 15, $30,000, whatever it maybe,
and after everything is done
it's valued at, say, 175.
We sell it at 110, 105, or 95.
Why?
Because you walk in with equity.
So the moment you buy your
home, you walk in with equity,
and all of the kind of internal
appointments of the home,
you know, the kitchen,
the lighting, you know,
the whole nine, the way that the heating
and air cooling system is done,
would be on the same level if you drove
to one of the well-off suburbs,
so using the same framing,
so when the downturn happens, you know,
you've got equity in your
home, and if you need,
because one of the ways
that Black people make money
in terms of wealth, past wealth,
is we've really done that
through home ownership.
So you've already, walking in,
you've got 25, $75,000 worth of equity.
That's only going to
increase, 10, 15, 20 years,
then you pass it on to your children
and it does not become a
burden, it becomes an asset.
So we're talking about, you know,
the idea of wealth building.
So we start purchasing these homes
and then something else happened
which we're dealing with now.
Then the speculators, these companies,
saw what we were doing and
they started grabbing the homes
on the tax delinquent
rolls in the Land Bank.
- Oh my goodness.
- And then trying to sell them without,
not even close to any kind of,
that means they're still falling apart,
trying to sell them at a higher price
or trying to sell 'em to us.
"Oh yeah, we'll give
it to you for 80,000."
I was like, "What're you talking about?
"This thing was on the rolls for 10."
That's a lot.
It's not livable.
You can't live in this
home, it's falling apart.
And so we see how
capitalism ends up trying
to undermine our community
when these speculators come in
and are basically just trying
to, you know, make a buck,
and we found out that all these companies,
all these individuals,
and not a single one of them
lives in the city of Chicago.
- Wow.
Wow.
That was the one,
I mean that was one of the
questions I was gonna ask
of just, I was gonna ask
about pushback but this is,
I mean that's a whole
nother level of just,
people trying to, yeah.
- It's another kind of white,
yeah, nother kind of white supremacy.
Here we have, we're doing
community rebuilding,
we're doing what we're supposed
to do, we're doing the work,
and then you have people literally outside
of the community say,
"Well I'm just gonna make a profit off
"of this working class,
this middle class community
"in Chicago because there's
not gonna be anybody
"that's gonna be an advocate for them."
They got another thing
coming, but we still.
- Yeah.
How do you maintain your hope
and your ability to not be jaded?
'Cause I'm hearing you say
this for the first time
and all sorts of reactions
are coming up inside me.
I'm just imagining how you
navigate that as a leader,
and how do you keep people encourage
in the midst of that?
- Well I'm, you know, I'm,
I know this sounds funny,
but I'm not trying to
be funny, but I'm Black.
I mean, I mean.
(both laugh)
- True.
- I mean, when I, because
I'm a lover of history,
and I'm a history nerd,
I'm a Black history nerd.
I'm into history, I'm
just nerd in general.
But especially history nerd, and--
- It's a good thing.
- When I read, it is, it
is, nothing wrong, you know,
nerds rule the world
in that way, right now.
But when I read stories of
Harriet Tubman, of Robert Small,
of Ida B. Wells, I don't have the right,
could you imagine Harriet Tubman saying,
"You know, I'm feeling kinda jaded.
"You know, I only got 300 out."
Like you got, do you
know what you just did?
You know, you were not only
a spy but you were also,
you're going back
and you're pulling these
people out of misery
and emancipating them spiritually.
I always think that our
ancestors are saying to us,
you know, "Otis, you
have all these resources
"and communities that you
can connect with and people.
"You have what your ancestors never had,
"and you don't have the
right to be cynical."
You have the right, you can get mad.
You have the right,
you can get ticked off,
and you can say the system
is rigged, but you don't,
all that being Black is is an act of hope.
Being Black is an act of resistance.
Being Black in this country means
that you are from the
descendants of people who refused
to give in to despair, and said,
"I shall rise up again,"
and that's one of the beautiful things
about the Black church.
The Black church is not
the white church in,
you know, Black face.
You know, we have our own theology.
We have a theology that says,
that speaks about, you know,
I don't know, you know, when,
but I know it shall, you know,
that we have this, it might
not come when you wanna,
you know, but, and this was,
these were these acts of resistance.
We always place it in this
kind of ephemeral frame
of Black people just, you know,
some type of opioid or
something of that nature
for the masses, borrowing
from this, you know,
this Marxian idea, but in the reality,
we were in the midst of
absurdity and tragedy.
We were framing, creating
the scaffolding for hope,
and that hope was not
something that was out there.
The hope was that I am a child of God,
the hope was that I have the ability.
That's what Frederick Douglass did.
He said, this was the
most articulate orator
in the history of America,
who never went to school.
Because he, there was one simple kernel
that Howard Thurman says.
He said, "The moment that
enslaved Black people recognized
"that they were loved,
"and they were loved by something greater
"than what was before them,
then resistance, resilience,
"and revolution was always
a part of their spirit."
- Mm.
So well said, I mean
just that perspective.
I appreciate you just
highlighting that in so many ways,
I mean, in a lot of
ways it's just something
that we need to talk about
more and more and more,
because it's not,
we don't all have the
Carter G. Woodson Library,
unfortunately.
That needs to be replicated.
That's a whole
nother conversation.
- That's right,
everybody needs a Woodson Library, really,
every community does.
It's a great library.
- I mean, have there been conversations?
I know you all are focused on, you know,
the work in the South Side of Chicago,
but conversations on ways to
expand this to other areas
or help replicate, I mean,
just with colleagues that you have
in other locations?
- Yeah.
We've been even talking about, you know,
maybe the possibility of doing
a conference, because we,
it's not just the Woodson
Library in with the church.
We have 27 acres that we've purchased,
and we are developing
that, and that will be,
already has a medical
center on the property.
We're now doing the housing next.
It will eventually have an
urban farm, a five-acre farm,
and it'll have a hotel that we're trying
to do using the same
three principles, again,
Black folk gotta benefit,
gotta be sustainable,
and those who are,
gotta disrupt the mass
incarceration system.
Those three principles
always have to be used
in the development.
And we're gonna have a healing garden
in parts of the nature conservancy,
and so it'll be over the next 10, 15,
it's gonna take a while to finish it
but we've got phase one which was a,
and we're not talking about a free clinic,
we're talking about primary
care, medical facility,
and get this, this
always trips people out,
it's run by Black women.
You know, it's four
brilliant, four brilliant,
and I say it again, brilliant
doctors who run this facility,
and the facility is through
the largest healthcare provider
in Illinois, Advocate Health Care.
- Wow.
- And so we developed the
land, they partner with us,
and built the facility,
and it is a state-of-the-art
medical center, again,
in the heart of the South Side.
It's not, you know, the, you know,
there's nothing wrong with free clinics,
I'm not throwing shade there,
but many times when we
think about our community,
we're thinking about something
that is a federally subsidized clinic
that is not doing primary care,
but it's also doing care for, you know,
for people obviously
who don't have access,
but this is also
practicing preventive care,
so they send out nurses
- Mm, that's good.
- into the community to let
them know, "Hey, you know,
"can I come by your Big Wish meeting
"and lemme show you signs for a stroke?"
You know, because most of the time,
we end up going to the emergency room
for our healthcare instead
of doing the preventive work.
So the medical center is
working on preventive care,
which is really exciting, so
we're trying to create a model,
what does, what's the model
from cradle to the grave
if you wanna create a community,
what do you need to do,
and you know, church is kind of a heart.
The library's another anchor,
right, in our community,
which is right down the
street, and then a mile down,
you have this 27 acres
that is next door to
Chicago State University,
which has become a predominantly
African American college.
So we got a college,
a community, a church,
and the Carter G. Woodson Library,
all within a 2 1/2 mile radius,
and now this main artery
known as 95th Street,
we wanna develop that whole
street and not as gentrifying
but as a renaissance,
and we wanna be able to create
a model to say to everyone,
this is what you can do
in your neighborhood,
this is what you can do in your community,
this is how you build, you know,
build communities so that children thrive,
so people are not getting shot.
This is the long-term, hardcore
work that you have to do.
- Mm.
Wow, that's just amazing to hear about,
encouraging to hear about.
I'm having a little
juxtaposition in my mind,
so just to give you a little
bit of insight, earlier,
I guess a couple months
ago I was actually out
in Tulsa, Oklahoma. I
don't know if you know,
but they opened a new museum out there
on the 100-year anniversary
of the Tulsa Massacre.
- Yes.
- So to think about
everything that happened there
with Black Wall Street,
everything that changed,
and to put that in juxtaposition
with everything you all
are doing, it's just,
I don't even know if I
can put it into words,
but just hearing, holding those two
together is, yeah.
- The model, I mean,
we're history nerds here,
so that's, you know,
Tulsa is a model.
But Auburn Avenue, I mean the history
of Auburn Avenue in Atlanta is,
there're these streets everywhere
in the Black community that thrive.
I mean, if you go to New Orleans,
if you were to go to Jackson,
if you went to Memphis,
I mean every street,
there were like this five-block stretch,
minimum five blocks, of I'm
not talking about, you know,
little tiny little stores.
I'm talking about like
thriving businesses.
Attorneys, doctors,
restaurants, dry cleaners,
every kinda business you
could kinda think of,
and some places like in
Tulsa, they had hotels.
You know, I mean it was amazing.
Same thing with, on
Auburn Avenue in Atlanta,
it had this history.
So we wanna replicate that.
You know, that there
was a model that worked,
that was the model that worked,
and when you build these institutions
and you create the space
that allow people to thrive
and we find out that home
ownership plus jobs plus churches
that are engaged reduces
violence dramatically,
then add gardens to the table,
plus libraries and schools,
you then, the trend
goes down even farther.
And so that's what we're trying to do.
And then it's not rocket science
if you wanna change stuff,
it's, we've been doing it for a long time.
We know how to do it. We just
need to have the moral courage
to be able to move forward.
- Yeah.
So well said, and I'll, I
mean just inspiring I know
for a lot of our listeners,
especially as we've been hinting
at the fact that this history
is not readily taught.
Many people might be
hearing aspects of this
for the first time which I
think is also an important
and huge step.
Obviously you all have
done a wonderful job
of that already in your community,
but as much as this can be modeled
and expanded I think is so
important, so again, you know,
it's just really encouraging
to hear about all
that you're doing, in the midst,
in the midst of everything,
even as you opened up this conversation,
in the midst of everything
you're even experiencing
in your pastoral role
day to day, so I mean,
to me it's just deeply encouraging
to know what you all are about,
makes me wanna swing by at
some point just to get a,
even a firsthand glimpse,
- I hope you would,
we would love to have you.
- or get connected
with some of those doctors, those women,
Black women who are running things
and doing so, so
brilliantly, it's just, yeah.
I'm speechless but I'm talking a lot.
It's a mixture of the
combination of both coming out
at once, but any last words
that you wanna leave our
listeners with in terms
of either word of encouragement
or a word of challenge?
- I would say that you are birthed
and born with the power of
resilience and resistance.
Just needs to be nurtured.
Find spaces, find people
who will pour into you,
and when they pour into you,
make sure you pour into somebody else.
There's nothing more
dangerous than a person
who acts like a swamp instead
of acting like a canal.
Swamps have inlets with no outlet,
and that's why swamps
smell and things die.
But canals are designed to release
for those who are in need.
And so be a canal.
When someone pours into you,
that's all we're called to do.
Just don't be a swamp.
That's what America wants you to be.
- Amen to that.
Well again Dr. Moss,
just appreciate you taking
the time for everything
that you shared, all the
work that you all are doing
in community together.
So grateful and honored to be
able to host you here today.
Thank you again.
- Oh, it's my pleasure,
and we look forward to
seeing you in Chicago
some time.
- Yep,
that would be wonderful.
(hip-hop music)